hi Sandra I'm glad to ask answer your
question which is a really good one I'm
working very very hard as I have been to
the last couple of years to move the
United States the world's largest
economy rapidly into new technologies
particularly energy technologies I'm
convinced I mean it's a six trillion
dollar market there are six billion
potential users today they'll be 9
billion over the next 20 30 years that
is the market of the future and if we go
in that direction build a new grid in
the United States excite alternative and
renewable energy begin to build our
infrastructure that's associated with
that and with other things there are
countless jobs all the way up and down
the food chain every level of the
economic food chain gets excited by
those possibilities we unfortunately
simply haven't been investing in our
future in the same way our DNA is
innovation creativity entrepreneurial
activity and we've ignored it the last
10 or 15 years regrettably so you have
to go back to what President Kennedy did
when he committed to take America to the
moon we committed unbelievable resources
to that kind of research and that
produced all kinds of spin off into the
private sector that's the key innovation
research create the jobs invest in the
future and we'll put people back to work